PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today in this video,
what I'd like us to do
is work on some solid
of revolution problems.
Well, one solid of
revolution problem.
So what I want us to
do in this one is,
find the volume of the
solid generated by rotating
the region bounded by these
three curves, x equals 0,
y equals 5, and y
equals x squared
plus 1, about the y-axis.
And I'm forcing you--
or I'm requesting--
that you use the disk method.
So I want us to work on the
disk method in this case.
So why don't you take
a crack at the problem?
And then I'll be back.
OK, welcome back.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to work on finding the
volume of a solid generated
by rotating this region
that's bounded by the three
curves mentioned
about the y-axis.
And as I said before, we're
going to use the disk method.
So when you're solving
these problems,
the first thing you want
to do is give yourself
at least a rough sketch of
what this region looks like,
of with the region bounded by
these three curves actually
looks like.
So the first thing I'm going to
do before I do anything else,
is at least get a rough sketch
of what that region looks like.
And I'll do that over
here on the right.
So, let's see.
We know we've got the region--
let me actually even use
some different colored chalk.
We'll say the x equals 0
is actually the y-axis.
That's x equals 0.
And then y equals 5-- actually
we'll put that in last.
But y equals x squared plus
1 is the parabola y equals
x squared shifted up by 1.
So if this is y
equals 1, then it's
just roughly
something like this.
That might not look
like the best parabola
I've ever seen, but well.
Something roughly like that.
Maybe, as I said, rough sketch.
Maybe more like that.
And then, we want to also put in
the y equals 5, which I'll say
is roughly about here.
So I could-- notice I've
got these three curves.
This curve, this
curve, this curve.
So I'm interested in
this region right here.
Right?
Notice that if I also
include this region, when
I rotated that around, I'd
actually get the same solid,
whether I included
this region or not.
But in terms of doing
the integration,
I want to make sure I don't
count anything doubly.
So I'm just looking at what
happens when I take this piece
and I rotate it
around the y-axis.
So what do we want to do?
We said we want to
use the disk method.
Which means ultimately,
I'm looking for finding out
what the radius is.
Right?
I'm doing pi r squared
when I integrate.
So I'm interested in
finding this length-- that's
going to be our
radius-- and then
we rotate-- you
probably can't see
that, so let me just say that's
going to represent our radius.
And then when we rotate
that around the y-axis
we get our disk.
Right?
We've seen some
pictures of this before.
So I'm interested
in this length here.
And because I want to
use the disk method,
I'm forcing us to
figure out what
is this value in terms of y?
So we know we have,
well we know that y
equals x squared plus 1 there.
So in terms of y, this is
y minus 1 equals x squared.
So the square root of y
minus 1 is equal to x.
So this is the expression I'm
interested in as our radius,
as my radius.
Right?
And now, what I need
to do is figure out,
I know if this is the
radius I need to figure out,
since I'm doing
this in terms of y,
what this lower bound is for
y and what the upper bound is
for y.
And then I'm going
to be integrating
pi times the radius squared
over y, over the changes in y.
Now let's see.
This one's easy. y
equals 5 up here.
And what is this value here?
Well, the function
that I had here was y
equals x squared plus 1.
So when x is 0, y is 1.
So this is the value
where y equals 1.
So I know what I'm
interested in doing.
Again, let me write it down.
Is I'm integrating from 1
to 5 of pi r squared dy.
And now, I need to write
r as a function of y.
So r is square
root of y minus 1.
When I square that,
I just get y minus 1.
So what I'm really
interested in integrating is,
the integral from
1 to 5 of-- let
me put the pi outside, because
who cares-- pi times that
integral, y minus 1 dy.
And if I actually
evaluate this, figure out,
if I actually take the integral,
use my rules for polynomials,
I can get a numerical value.
I'm going to stop evaluating
here, because from here on I
know you guys can do it.
But, the point of
this problem, what
I want to mention, the
point of this problem
is the main thing we had
to do is figure out what
is the radius in terms of y.
That was the main thing
we had to figure out
in order to do this problem.
I said you had to use disks.
So we had to figure out what
the radius was in terms of y.
And then we had
to figure out what
the bounds were in terms of y.
And once we do that,
it's a simple matter
of evaluating this integral,
or finding the actual value
for what this integral is.
So I think that is
where I'll stop.